everyone stop everything you're doing
because we are coming to Europe on tour
trash taste Europe tour 2023 is
happening we are selling tickets right
now click the link down in the
description below but they're going fast
click the links down in the description
below do it I'll see you there I like
going uh to anime expert it's always
crazy I mean you just see the most
insane cosplayers the one character I
never understood because I didn't
realize it was this popular was uh jinko
enoshima Kimiko toga from my hero
Academia as well [__] oh my God what is
it with what is it with
welcome back to another episode of trash
taste oh my God oh my God way to go Joey
and I'm here once again with the boys
during gone and I'm your host for today
was that your way of saying hello Joey
was that your way of saying a lot that
is that is my way of saying hi I can't
walk I did a ring fit stream yesterday
and my legs don't function
yeah you uh what was it because uh you
don't have anywhere to cycle so you're
like I'm going to destroy my legs inside
my house now I don't know I wanted to do
a ring fit stream because I thought ring
fit was a fun game and I actually like I
actually play Ring fit like sometimes
casually right because it's fun and it
is fun yeah they have gamified exercise
Nintendo have done something right
because it was worryingly fun doing
exercise it's a fantastic game yeah it's
pretty well made
um and I you know I think casually it's
an amazing game I think grinding it is
absolutely [__] stupid I don't think
it's supposed to be grinding they won't
know because the game every every time
you clear a stage it's like all right
good job man uh I want to do those
cooldown stretches now and then I have
to keep pressing like no
um so it keeps going but I I don't know
I thought hi I wonder I wonder if I can
burn 1 000 calories on the in-game
um like thing yeah and I wondered how
long that would take and so I thought
well what did it take uh eight hours of
in-game time
one of the exercise too so I was like
are you alive right now well I can't
walk I actually had to get stretched
into the set today no I yeah I woke up
with such immense pain because it's all
like stretches yoga squats
um and I don't know I just thought it
would be fun and I guess I didn't
consider how it would [__] me the
next day and I'm still tired like I
slept like nine hours and I'm still
tired no [__] but was it fun was it fun
it was pretty fun actually yeah it was I
mean it's like ring fit again it's a
goaded game like the music goes
unfathomably hard yeah but for eight
hours bro yeah eight hours yeah it was
too long and like I tweeted out being
like hey I beat I beat I got 1 000
calories in ring fit which by the way I
didn't know the calorie counter only
goes up to 999 and then it doesn't roll
up
[Music]
and uh everyone's like really only 1 000
calories in eight hours I was like oh
yeah [__] course it's not 1 000
calories like what do you this game is
yeah this is ring fit calories yeah the
game also like [__] lies about how
much you're burning it is because like
my I was wearing two different fitbits
and they both said I burned 5 000
calories by the end of it
um how do you not just like Skin and
Bones bro I'm John what do you mean I
got junk in the trunk a lot of reserves
to work through
um but but I mean if there was a
direction to lie about how many calories
you're burning I think it's better to uh
be inactive for sure about you know
burning less calories than just
overestimating it and being like Oh yeah
I bought like 5 000 calories last night
actually I mean like senior ring fit
says five yeah
exercises you're like yeah this makes
sense this wouldn't burn that many and
then when you're doing Squatch you're
like there's no way this is four
calories
this feels like 500 calories like I yeah
it's too much yeah all right the the
important thing is though like okay so
it's a game right did you find a way to
like break the game in any way during
those eight hours to be like um
I'm doing the exercise but I don't feel
like I'm doing the exercise in the way
they're intended is it possible it's a
speed run ring food yeah absolutely so
the trick to speedrunning is I guess the
first level you would get to a ledge and
normally the game will tell you to jump
over it but your character will keep
running yeah and when you're running
you're burning calories right and the by
far the quickest way to burn calories
like in real life is to run yeah it goes
up a lot faster so if you literally just
stand in place and jog for like two
hours right a thousand calories which I
think actually is kind of accurate I I
think if you stood in place for two
hours and jogged you probably would burn
yeah probably I think around that yeah
that sounds about right maybe maybe not
maybe a little bit less God damn it I
can never get away from the running it's
always the right turns out it always
comes back to the best way to burn
calories is just to run
um or like cycle or do any kind of
cardio intensity exercise yeah uh
running I don't like doing as much
normally because it hurts my legs after
a while I maybe it's because I have
improper running form I don't know but I
that's why I like cycling it's like you
can't [__] it up swimming's also great
too so it looks like actually a full
body which I really enjoy but Japan is
just allergic to pools yeah uh this
pool's [__] nowhere unless you pay
like 500 a month for membership yeah
it's pay to win for the swing yeah but
it's like even then it's like there's
nowhere like there's one like it's kind
of close to me but it's still just a
little bit inconvenient it's like dude
I'm not gonna go swimming if it's like
[__] so far away yeah exactly so it
means op is [__] though yeah yeah but
so that's me getting because I was
getting tired of doing these 12-hour
streams where I just sat there and at
the end of the day I'd be like yeah I'm
tired from all that streaming I look at
my Fitbit it's like you walked 1 000
steps today I'm Jesus Christ I'll be
honest because I tried streaming a bit
more this past month uh even though most
of it is just one single game yeah which
you can probably guess what it is I'm
just like I I it's just I remember like
fin finishing a day of streaming and
some days I'd stream like you know six
hours and I just feel like wow I've done
nothing with today and tomorrow I'm
gonna wake up and do nothing
I'm like how do streamers do this my
mind has literally gone to Mush I did it
for a week and I'm like no I I actually
because I guess because you have if
you're a full-time streamer yeah you're
like oh this is my this is how I make
money right but I guess for you it's
like well I got obligations I have main
videos to work with no because the thing
is I did feel like I was still okay it's
it's so weird because I'm like I'm
streaming but I'm I always felt like I
was tricking my brain into doing work
when I actually wasn't doing work even
though like I was making money and you
know I was making like second Channel
videos and everything like that uh so
technically I was working but it never
felt like I don't know the work that I
was doing never felt like actual work it
just felt like I was tricking I had
found like a like a [__] work hack to
be like yes I'm actually working on
making money but am I doing anything to
benefit Society I don't know if I I
don't know if I do would you use
categorize your normal videos is
benefiting you know what after I didn't
but after I've done streaming for like
two weeks I'm like maybe maybe yeah I'm
benefiting Society like most self-aware
streamer on the planet
like I can't just do like only game
streams like constantly because I just
feel like I'm not doing anything yeah
I'm like I gotta like so this is like
you know and lately I've been trying to
pack more streams in and manage my
schedule which means normally something
needs to get cut out and it's only the
gym yeah so it's like [__] because you
know the time for streaming in Japan uh
again this is like YouTuber talk so I'm
sorry I didn't give a [__] because we we
live in this time zone right the best
time zone to start streaming normally
it's pretty early in the morning for us
or late at night yeah uh and if I start
at like 1pm it's like No One's Gonna
watch yeah because everyone's in
everyone and every other time zone can't
really watch that so it's kind of like
all right well [__] you yeah um so
normally if you stop pretty early but I
hate going to the gym at night so it's
like if I want to go to the gym I go I
got to go I'm gonna stream at night go
to the gym in the morning all right so
therefore Stream ring fit and therefore
you fix your own problem do a week's
worth of exercise in one stream that's
not that's not how Exercise Works I know
that it's not joking
um yeah I mean I you know I I just
wanted to do something kind of weird and
contribute to society actually that's a
big part where are you contributing I
informed people how many hours it takes
to burn a thousand calories from ring
fan
there's your contribution to society
absolutely
yeah I think you probably feel that way
about streaming because you you it's not
your full-time like it's not your focus
so I think if you I could I don't think
I could make it my full-time Focus but
after trying it for a week I'm like I
don't know I feel
I
it's it's weird right because I you know
there are some there are some streams
where you're like yeah that was that was
really fun and then some of them you
were just like that was really
mind-numbing and I was just playing a
game for eight hours uh didn't really
feel like I did anything uh and I
couldn't imagine doing that every single
day when I wake up and I'm like
don't really have anything to talk about
because all I did was uh play a game for
eight hours uh yeah that was that was my
life the problem is you found the joy of
touching grass that's that's that's
you're also bringing a lot of
um
there's a lot of the streaming when I
guess it can be it's easier is when you
kind of only get content or you only get
like stuff to talk about from the thing
that you're doing yeah you're not
relying on external things yeah yeah
topics to talk about yeah obviously
there could be things to talk about but
yeah I know that that's one of the
biggest problems of streaming is that it
dedicates so much for your life you
almost get like no other life
experiences yeah yeah because your whole
entire life is just this thing yeah
whereas YouTube right you could I could
make I remember I used to do this uh
back when my videos took a lot less work
and I still thought I was working really
hard because you know you know how it is
when you're YouTube yeah of course oh my
God I work so hard and you're like I
would make like three videos in one week
and I would just do nothing for three
weeks because then I was like oh this is
sick that's what I do right now
Joey's on like special oh my gig up
schedule exactly because you're like man
I work so hard and you're like wait I
have like four days a week empty I'm
like I don't work that hard yeah I I I I
open all the stuff I'm doing all this I
organize yeah but I mean I guess you're
like nonsense you're working on stuff
like that so that makes sense right like
that's just how your priorities shift
yeah
um but yeah streaming is just so time
and intensive uh dude I don't know man
it's weird yeah freaks yeah that's why I
went to uh touchgrass this weekend
actually after a week or two weeks of
streaming yeah I went to to I didn't
realize uh this was going on until the
weekend actually there was a Thai
Festival in Tokyo and like one of the
biggest festivals okay uh outside of
Thailand Thai culture yeah got a little
piece of home which was interesting uh
so I turned up to this uh I turned up to
this hey where are you guys there huh my
homies okay but first
thing uh the only place in the world
where I literally did not know what
language to speak like so
English Japanese yeah do I do I speak
English do I speak Japanese do I speak
to I remember like oh so I turned up and
uh within like two hours a fan
recognizes me and we start the
conversation he asks uh if he could take
a picture in Japanese or blind Japanese
we uh have a short Japanese exchange uh
then Sydney comes in and uh she she
wants to flex her the little tie that
she knows so she starts speaking to
women Thai she uh she he replied Eisen
tie speaks back to me in Japanese but
then I I notice we're starting to speak
in Thai so I reply in Thai right and
then another another fan recognizes me
starts speaking to me in English so the
conversation just switches to English
and I'm just like this is I feel like
I'm in like that YouTube video where
it's just like a polyglot reflects how
many languages they can speak because we
would it was it was so [__] weird
because everyone there was basically
bilingual at least yeah most of them
were like how many of them were like
actually Thai
um quite a lot actually yeah so there
were quite a lot of Thai people there
um and it's so most of it was like food
stores and everything like that uh but
there was one uh so I was I was looking
around to see what's uh what store had
the longest line because I was like I
wanted the best Thai food I miss home I
wanted the I wanted a piece of the home
so I look around and I see one store had
by far the longest line out of any stall
in the entire Festival right all right
and I like I I subconsciously just start
lining up just in case I want to do and
so I like tracked the line and the
line's so long that it kind of like
loops around so it's it's like it's like
a line loops around and it Loops back
around again and I'm like oh what is
this line for
and slide for the [__] garbage
I [__] I [__] you not what they cooking
kind of Ransom
but I bet it's good I smell durian
oh no it's [__] I don't know if this is
a normal thing for like Japanese
festivals because this is kind of like
the first Festival that I've been to
um so they don't they they have they
don't have like they don't have like
bins there they have like garbage stalls
where you have the same olds you know
you you have the same kind of like
station where you can separate your
garbage but they have an actual like uh
they have an actual stand for that or
like it's like manned yeah it's like man
oh yeah man that must be a [__] show
yeah yeah so so the problem was there's
only so many stores where you could get
rid of your garbage because there were
no public bins yeah of course
um so I don't know if this is normal for
a Japanese festival because uh I went
there and most of the time uh most of my
uh waiting time was uh waiting to get
rid of the [__] I I kept buying yeah
unfortunately I was very hungry and I
wanted to go to as many stores as
possible so anytime I bought something I
was like Fox Lake I go like I got like a
Thai Noodle in my hand and I can't I
can't put it anywhere no which uh that's
very Japanese yeah which kind of kind of
shows
how dedicated the Japanese culture is to
uh following rules and not littering
because I swear to God if this was in
place because at bare minimum to get rid
of any garbage even if you had like a
single bottle in hand it was like a 15
minute wait
a while to get together I would just eat
the plastic
what I would have done is just like I
would have gone to like the nearest
company or something yeah buy something
get a plastic bag and just hold that
[__] yeah that's what I would have done
yeah and then like once I'm like back at
a station or another company or
something because because it was uh so
[__] frustrating to get rid of just
the simplest thing but at the same time
no one littered I was [__] it I I was
amazed there was not a single like there
was not a single piece of garbage I saw
at this massive Festival which had like
two thousand like yeah because any other
country if they see a line to throw [__]
out people would just be like [__] this
yeah just like stop littering right yeah
let's make a pile yeah yeah I'll start
everyone join in yeah especially when
you're throwing alcohol into that mix as
well which was the biggest like I can't
I can't believe this is actually
happening people are getting drunk in
public and people are actually still
conscious enough to uh throw their [__]
away and wait in line to throw their
[__] away
um but yeah it props up to the job
Japanese people uh I didn't know this
but uh I went there and uh I didn't know
there were Thai Idols that uh were a
thing as well titles uh titles titles uh
so there was uh you know there was a
main stage where you know different
concerts and different performances uh
were going on and I was like Sydney we
got it we got a bear in hand one let's
let's watch some let's watch some time
musicians perform and uh we go in and
they go so next uh next man coming off
is a bkt 48 and I was like
ain't no way this is a [__] thing and
yeah and apparently uh or on steps on
bkt48 I guess the uh I guess uh Bangkok
went uh we want akb-48 at home and uh
Bangkok Thailand 48. yeah yeah I think
it's uh just bkt which is like uh
Bangkok yeah Bangkok Thailand 48 uh yeah
Bangkok have their own bkt 40 year and I
found out that basically every doing
research I was like there's no way
there's no way this is real yeah uh it
is real uh apparently there's a Bangkok
sister Idol from akb48 and there's it
there's jkt 48 as well
no way I had I had no idea this was a
thing oh my God and they basically all
do the same songs they it's it's like
they all do the same songs wait sir are
they like original General songs are
there like covers from akb48 some of
them I believe some of them are covers
and some of them this is my name though
oh and I I was like I was like I hate
Idol groups yeah I I do too but I just
love that concept I'm just like let's
just take the city name condense it down
to three letters and get 48 of them yeah
and do that for every country
are you serious jkt
that's
just like what is the [__] point of
having 48 members that's so [__] many
because you get all the choice in the
world to choose who you who your or she
is right yeah so I have basically zero
knowledge about akb48 so I I kind of I
kind of missed uh I kind of missed that
train
oh you're probably better off to be
honest yeah yeah it was so [__] weird
right because obviously this was a Thai
festival and uh you know even though
there are a lot of Thai Idol fans uh I'm
sure uh this Festival was full of just
you know different members uh of uh
people who just wanted to come to the
Thai festival and you just saw the
dichotomy between there were like one or
two hardcore bkt 48 fans that were just
like there was one there was there were
two people that were just like sitting
on each other's shoulders yeah and just
like hardcore you you know you know when
you you know the choreography where you
like go you like they're those guys that
just lean into it yeah yeah it's not
just like they they know like like the
choreography they're like oh
[__] uh like it's like they're doing
a full-on exercise they're leaning into
this 100 and then they're just like some
Thai grandmas to be like I don't know
what's going on right now but I'm going
to clap I'm going to class this is the
karaoke should I go up on stage
Corrections apologies
I don't know how that discussion of the
original akb48 got to 48. some guy was
like 20. the guy was like more they were
like
30. yeah more
like 50. that's too much yeah
I just want to know why why 48. it's so
[__] I'm sure this is this is one
this is one thing I never understood
about idle groups that were that big you
know like up to like let's say eight is
like pushing it for me 10 is like the
maximum to how many I can like
reasonably follow along with I'm just
trying to think of what I feel Kpop
groups got it the best where it's like
they limit it to between like five and
fifteen like I think that's like a
manageable size even 15. even 50 yeah
five five five five to ten is like a
manageable size yeah I don't know why I
view him I don't know why my mind has
made its distinction but I view like
K-pop bands I suppose very differently
to how I view Idols I guess they all
kind of different because I mean they
are Idols yeah they are Idols but I
guess they're the way that they Market
themselves very different right whereas
is it though do they in a weird sense I
think K-Pop group groups almost ah
I think they again they shouldn't be
talking out my ass somebody doesn't
consume either of them yeah in my head I
feel like whereas the idols focus on
I suppose catering to the customer and
interacting with the customer uh
directly K-pop groups tend to focus more
on releasing music and having kind of I
don't know in my head it's just I guess
I see it as like his idols most Idols
it's all about the fan meetups it's all
about the handshake times you know
whereas it feels that the K-pop groups
are more like yeah I'd be a fan but it's
mainly you consume it and interact with
it through all of the the media I mean I
disagree because I could be wrong yeah
yeah this is the perspective of a man
who's talking out of his ass he doesn't
consume either I mean I'm not super
knowledgeable or either but I know for a
fact that like in Japan at least you
know like when when we think of like
Japanese Idols right like akb48 usually
the first one like just large groups of
like Japanese girls all dressed the same
you know interacting with fans like you
know if it's like the underground Idol
scene and stuff like that but like Japan
also has a massive male Idol culture as
well like there are so many [__]
super groups of like just just dudes
yeah who are doing basically like you
know boy band [__] like you know
Backstreet Boys type stuff right and
it's like and a lot of that Underground
scene is yeah from the most Parts
majority filled with like all female
groups but there's also some like highly
highly dedicated like male groups as
well that do the same thing I think it's
just that there's because that whole
like underground scene of like the the
all goal groups has just been so well
documented compared to the male
counterpart maybe that's it that I think
a lot of people just aren't aware that
no there's male equivalents so many
documentaries about the idol industry
exactly and they're all based around
like the female groups right yeah yeah I
remember there's one that released where
it was like it was they were they were
interviewing people who are fans of
underground Idol groups and there was
one where it was like I guess the mom
was getting her like 12 year old
daughter to be an idol oh I saw that
yeah and there was like a bunch of 40
year old dudes who were like paying to
have zoom calls with her yeah
it was [__] weird yeah it was like it
was just so bizarre and it was like she
would do live streams on some I don't
know some weird website it wasn't like
any of the mainstream ones and she would
get like a thousand viewers and she was
like 13. yeah I think like this is weird
I actually I actually do remember there
there is an app in Japan or website
that's specifically I think it's called
ichinana or something yeah it was like
one of those where you can like and you
just like you watch them and you have to
like keep paying yeah yeah it's
basically like cam going except they're
not like doing sexually just like
talking basically yeah but like you can
tip to like have conversations with them
live right yeah and it's very I mean one
it's parasocial as [__] but yeah it's
also just like
a little creepy I mean I mean I'm the
one to judge people who want to yeah you
want to stream and make money because
that's what I [__] in my opinion it's
a bit creepy yeah yeah I think I think
it's like you know it'd be hypocrite
hypocritical of me to be like man look
at these people going online and asking
for money from people yeah because you
know it's actually what I [__] do uh
although thank you
thank you thank you
but I I feel like I feel like uh the
creepiness uh what it could because I
feel like when you shoot a 12 year old
[__] dude in the mum's encouraging
yeah I mean we've seen that on like
YouTube as well you know some some
parents yeah
are definitely yeah like Shilling their
kids but I I guess it's because you you
in this documentary the one that was on
YouTube and I can't remember who did it
it's one of the journalists it was like
they would go and interview the dudes
who were consuming it which were like 50
year old man yeah and then that's where
you're like
you know because if it's a if it's a kid
a kid you like Ryan's toy reviews where
other kids are watching yeah they're
like okay that's I mean there's still
got to be some kind of questionable
thing what's going on here with the
parents how they're involved is this is
it you know is it is it being run the
like in a way that is fair to the kid
you know yeah yeah yeah yeah is the
money going to the kid or not all those
questions need to be answered obviously
but it's it's like it's like it's like
fine yeah I mean obviously you would
want kids to be within kids content
because it helps you know that's that
yeah yeah they want to be represented uh
they don't give a [__] they just want to
see other kids uh living cool lives
because that's swag but the fact that if
like 50 year old men were consuming it
and you would like you'd see this dude
on like a zoom call with like this girl
and she's like 12 and you're like why
yeah like it is the most like morally
questionable thing that you could ever
see it's [__] weird even though he
may be he may go into it just like
completely [__] innocent right like
on on all you know all circumstances
right you were fair enough but still
like when you just look at it at the
surface your first instinct is what's
going on there's absolutely no need for
a 50 year old man to be interacting with
a kid in any way that is not like a
professional like a doctor or something
you know what I mean like exactly like
if you were just hanging out with kids
and you're paying to hang out with your
kids I'm definitely
you would be on a watch list on any
other country
yeah I I mean I just find like I've
always found the psychology of the idol
industry fascinating you know yeah
especially with while watching these
documentaries because a lot of the times
you you know a lot of times you come and
you're like oh anyone you know if if
you're a
um
if you're a businessman watching this
kind of stuff then obviously there's
something nefarious going on and I would
say from most of the documentaries I've
seen a lot of these people it's more of
just like they are just lonely and it's
kind of like they have like a sad story
you know with like the with the adult
Idol yeah with the adults I was like
okay yeah yeah with the adult I'm sorry
I was gonna say I was like all right if
you're lonely don't talk to a [__]
12-year-old
let the 12 year olds yeah go to the
other 12 year olds come on yeah yeah
um it's it's like it's like it to me I
find it like really interesting to see
what kind of psychology goes into how
someone really really gets you know
honestly kind of like addicted to uh
total loneliness yeah and I think
there's a lot of um conversation online
about like male loneliness but the
problem is a lot of the time he gets
hijacked by like in cells and very like
Wing conversations yeah so a lot of the
times it's kind of not it's kind of hard
to talk about but you know I do I do
think a lot of dudes out there are very
lonely yeah guys aren't good at
expressing their emotions or talking
about it so it's very hard for them to
kind of open up and kind of learn about
themselves more and know how to express
yourself so I think a lot of guys turn
to things like at least in Japan where
it's even compounded even more I think
yeah yeah you know the moment you leave
High School you don't really get pushed
to socialize much is that just
compounding like lifelong loneliness
that when you get to this age you're
like I have disposable income like a
cute girl can talk to me who's very
talented and yeah I can feel like we're
friends and yeah of course like this is
gonna happen especially when people are
marketing and telling you hey this isn't
weird look at all the other dudes who
are doing this you know what I mean so
it's kind of like this whole thing
that's compounding just from Japanese
society and I feel like it's happening
slowly in the like kind of Western world
but but more with other services do you
think maybe that aspect is the reason
why I like uh say like southeast Asia
like the whole [__] existence of bnk
48 and jkt 48 like do you think maybe
that maybe do you think maybe it's like
an Asian thing
I think yes uh I think definitely in
terms about in terms of just opening up
and talking about your feelings
especially in Thailand uh uh when I was
growing up mental health issues just
weren't really a thing you know it's one
in the UK until I was like 10. exactly
and even now it's still I would argue
that it's still uh especially in our
parents generation you know people in
the west may have been more aware and
may have heard about it more but it
feels like at least in you know Thai
culture and Asian culture it's not
really talked about like at all and you
know there are some things that you come
across in let's say Asian family
gatherings that uh that are just kind of
like normalized uh it's kind of like
normalized in Asian culture you go to a
family gathering and eat whatever
whatever weight you are you better be
prepared for your in-laws and your found
me to talk about your weight whether
you're too thin or you're too fat and
you are never the perfect to wait you
are either two Goldilocks does not exist
exactly exactly it doesn't matter too
little too much it doesn't matter if
you're [__] ripped as [__] you've
been going to the gym every day you've
they're like yo have you been carb
loading I feel like you've been carb
loading a little too much recently they
will find any way to not compliment you
yeah yeah and uh the thing is the the
only way to solve that issue is to eat
more I don't know what it is about even
if uh they say that you overweight as
[__] they'll say you're overweight in
the same sentence where they sell tell
you to eat like 10 dishes that they've
took for you I don't know why
the psychology I don't I don't know yeah
um because I just I just don't see that
whole Idol thing existing outside of
Asian countries like could you imagine a
[__] lnd 48 in London or like a crd48
in Cardiff like it's just it's just
never gonna happen although it would be
kind of Epic I think I think it's like
that doesn't I don't know why I think it
just doesn't jump well with the with the
Western mindset like of like that's how
they kind of get rid of that loneliness
I don't think that's how they do it but
then we have stuff like only fans and
stuff yeah a lot of guys turn to yeah
my stream is just in general I think
yeah yeah but I think I think even then
like the way that the Japanese youtubing
set up to Western youtubing is very very
different I I think I think so I think
so yeah I think at least the way the
audience approach it yeah I think the
big difference between east and west and
in this kind of sense is that
um I I feel like idols and let's say
um you know only fan streamers and all
that kind of stuff we're both kind
they're both kind of sell a similar
product right uh it's it's like the kind
of like parasocial kind of thing where
you feel like you have a connection with
that person or with that streamer yeah
uh I just feel like here with Idols it's
just a bit more in your face and I've
what I feel like the big difference is
that
um at least in the west people don't
want to feel like they're being sold
something yeah they don't feel like a
fan they want to feel like a friend yeah
yeah so I think when they're when
they're sold a Fan Experience yeah at
least with some people I don't think it
resonates as widely as yeah there needs
to be that natural feeling of like
self-discovery yeah yeah it's just like
I wasn't sold this I made the conscious
choice to be like oh okay I I discovered
them for myself and you slowly spiraled
down into that rabbit hole whereas with
Idols it's like front and center here
are the girls they can be your friends
okay if you just paid the money they
will be your friends they will shake
your hands all right and then Japanese
people like it's that easy okay
it's like you know you can and if you
keep buying their albums maybe they'll
go on a lunch date yeah yeah something
like that you know what I mean it's like
that's true it is you know it's it's a
lot of the times and the same thing with
like girls bars right like dudes will go
to the same bar in the hopes that they
might they've paid enough money at one
point to hopefully get a date yeah yeah
yeah I also almost feel like at least in
the west the whole idea of like boy
bands and like Idol groups and stuff
like that is kind of like a past thing
like because like I don't know I feel
like J uh K-pop has really that's that
they sounded like yeah I feel I feel
like Western boy bands and girl bands
have kind of you know I mean the last
one I could think of was like Backstreet
Boys Like Nsync and that was like
[__] 20 plus years ago right so it's
like since then we haven't the West
hasn't really adopted that style at
least in like the music scene it's just
because well it just goes cable yeah I I
just realized because K-pop is just so
[__] dominant yeah no one can do it
as well I also think that you know you
have to look at the LA landscape of uh
you know agencies and contracts like in
Korea you know it's still a lot and you
know Asia in general yeah the contracts
uh you know normally very heavily
favored in the producer or the person
making the group you can say that yeah
you know whereas over the years you know
especially in places like California and
stuff like that like contracts have
become you know very very uh or
documented that it used to be a lot of
abuse right so yeah now nowadays you
kind of can't make these contracts
they're all very one-sided and you can't
force the talent to do a bunch of stuff
they didn't agree to so yeah there's
like a realistic like do do we do you
really think that half of these Idol
groups or bands perform as much if they
didn't have a producer who had a lot of
the power kind of pushing them to do
more right like realistically there'd
probably be less because did you hear
about like the Backstreet Boys contract
that they were on it's pretty obviously
you know you know like Backstreet Boys
right like this is one of the most
[__] popular Western boy bands of all
time do you know how much money they
walked away with when they disbanded I
don't know how much 100 okay what yeah
well yeah like that's crazy it's so [__]
they sold that many songs the like most
well-known boy band walked away with
100K yeah that's like that should never
happen yeah yeah like and I imagine
there's something that I you know I'm
just speculating that I imagine the
deals you know
um are always
very very heavily leaning towards way
favorite for the talent yeah it's like
for the agency yeah like you know like
in Japan like mcm's or like agencies for
YouTubers you know even though it's like
a modern thing like they're still like
very heavily skewed towards whoever's
running yeah so not not the YouTuber
yeah like I think the pretty common ones
like like for one of the YouTube uh
networks or something here was like 20
for the talent it's like 20 or 30 for
the talent yeah which is like egregious
yeah you know to give more prefer uh to
explanations what it is normally in the
west it's like tops 10 nowadays yeah it
used to be 20 you'd hear a lot but 10 is
they're kind of a stand for the agency
yeah 10 for the agency uh and yeah 90
for the talent because you're the one
making yeah exactly you're the one who
does everything so yeah you know that
makes more sense
um yeah I mean I feel like a big change
is that back then agencies just had a
lot more power uh for sure because the
internet didn't exist and now you you
because you know back when back in the
day there was no way to if you wanted to
be like independent to get your name out
there because you'd have to rely on
these big agencies that had all the
marketing power and they were like we
can get you into stores and get you in
people's Radars where now you can have a
song go viral or uh anything like a
video go viral and there that's boom
that's your name out you're now
independent you know
um so I feel like you know it's more
power to the artist Because the Internet
you know we complain a lot about the
inside for a lot of things but this is
one of the good thing that's come out of
it you know yeah this episode is
sponsored by PayPal honey the easy way
to save When shopping on your iPhone or
computer but did you know it only takes
a few seconds to get it that means if
you watch this episode on your laptop or
iPhone you can get honey as soon as this
ad ends but Connor what even is honey
let the audience know imagine you're
shopping on one of your favorite sites
when at the checkout the honey button
appears and all you have to do is Click
apply coupons that's it wait a few
seconds is honey for coupons you can
find for that site and if honey finds a
working coupon you'll watch the prices
drop
oh you know what else Works fast Honey's
deal finding abilities honey is the free
shopping tool that scours internet for
promo codes and applies the best one it
finds to your cart Connor what did you
save money on with honey actually saved
30 on a brand new TV stand because I got
a new TV recently which was thanks to
honey but honey doesn't just work on
desktops it works on your iPhone too
just activate it on Safari on your phone
and save on the go getting honey
seriously only takes a few seconds I
could have done it now you could have
honestly done it now and by getting it
you're not only doing yourself a solid
butt you'll be supporting the boys as
well in a few seconds only a few seconds
so get PayPal honey for free at join
honey.com trash taste that's
joinhoney.com trash taste links in the
description below back to the episode
what I found really interesting is that
um in like vtubing I've noticed that
they even though it's you might like a
particular YouTuber from a particular
company yeah I've realized that they've
been like the the
groups have been really really smart
about getting you invested more so in
the brand name as opposed to the talent
so that when you're like oh this we
don't want this Talent anymore it's like
all right well people will still want
the brand it was pretty impressive yeah
yeah and it's like I think if if Idol
companies have figured this out this
would be game over the contracts would
be like 100 to zero well I mean yeah you
pay us well I mean Japan basically did
that with the with the Johnny's Group
which is like oh yeah the biggest like
Idol which is right now getting a lot of
[__] wasn't that the guy who was like
sexually harassing what's this yeah I I
haven't heard about this uh so uh the
the guy who found it yeah so I don't
know the full story I was gonna make a
section I think he made like boy okay
this again like maybe you could pull up
a battery yeah so Johnny so Johnny's is
basically the biggest uh Idol uh agency
in Japan for boys boys right uh so like
they produce like smap arashi like
pretty much like all the top [__] boy
bands in Japan which were [__] huge
um and the guy who owned it uh Johnny
something he's like a half Japanese guy
um he I think he died recently and all
these allegations came out about how he
was just like horribly sexually abusive
these allegations had been known
publicly for like 20 plus years yeah but
you know in Japan uh a lot of the
agencies have a [__] ton of power over
the media because uh you oh you have a
Saturday TV show that has variety if you
talk [__] about any of our agency you
[__] goodbye Talent well I mean if
you turn on if you turn on Japanese TV
at any time during the day there was at
least one Johnny's Idol member like
hosting or co-hosting or being on one of
these shows like they are everywhere on
Japanese TV and so yeah like this
[__] story camera but like you know
as you were saying with uh with YouTube
agencies I feel johnnys has done that
where it's like even if one group
disappears or they disband or whatever
and a new group comes out and you think
to yourself oh this is just a new group
yeah you know whatever oh they're part
of Johnny's though yeah yeah okay now I
gotta [__] check it out you know and
it's like they've used the name Johnny's
as like a brand power to be like even if
it's someone completely new completely
irrelevant to what you used to like yeah
just based on their association with
that agency people are just instantly on
that yeah and that kind of power that he
had allowed him to do heinous very
horrible yes for decades yeah right um
you know and he got away with it because
now he's dead yeah even though even
though it was publicly known that he was
doing this before and it was reported
elsewhere you know it was never pushed
in any of the uh the the news here again
because Japanese news is a former I've
seen this very of you know they don't
report things negatively a lot about the
government ever and they they let's say
if there's a talent agency again if
you're going to report negatively you
don't get any challenging shows so that
that story almost reminded me of that
what's that British I was gonna say this
reminds me of Jimmy Savage Jimmy Savile
yeah yeah it is literally like that yeah
I was like yeah British so much better
we would never do that that would never
happen anything this has probably
happened in many many many many
countries yeah yeah you're so popular
that you can get away with doing this
heinous [__] yeah yeah uh or you can
just use your company's influence to
bully other companies around yeah do
what you want and it's [__] up but hey
I mean again when we when we called the
[__] out in Japan or whatever it's not
that we're trying to be like look at
Japan look at all the problems yeah it's
like no obviously [__] the UK is a
[__] mess yeah what happens
everywhere I just think it's important
to point out and talk about it when you
talk about the whole industry as a whole
yes exactly of course I mean everyone
knows that there are some uh dodgy [__]
going in the Auto industry we everyone
knows that now you know it's like the
worst kept secret and yeah I the idol
like [__] jet like companies yeah
everyone knows that they're treated like
[__] yeah yeah that's why we're watching
oshinoka right yeah yeah
they shall a dream and that's why they
could yeah that's that's the thing no
matter how much comes out as long as you
sell that dream uh people are going to
buy into it you know see that's why
that's why Idol master was a five head
move because you can't abuse an anime
characters
that's that was their way of being like
these pathetic human beings with their
emotions they're too unreliable yeah
yeah we can milk them for money but we
should make AIS or [__] characters
that have their own mind and we'll say
what I want them to say and we'll
promote anything I want them to promote
yeah and then that way I don't have to
worry about it everyone wins if a
person's okay with it yeah I'm gonna
[__] do it but that it is just a
matter of time before that happens like
the like the first AI Idol group or the
first AI V tuber group you know we've
we've we've gotten to the point now did
you hear about that uh influencer the
maids and AI version of themselves uh
you mean was it amaranth yeah she just
announced it another streamer who's
doing another only fans person who was
doing yeah yeah yeah amarantha is coming
out with her own like AI version on the
cell phone yeah yeah imagine just
jacking off to like an AI conversation
just like what the [__] yeah man can you
imagine like a trash cheese one who's
like hey you can have a conversation
with the boys come come come drink with
us man
yeah you're just like uh pooping poop
and stinky
bread
it's like are you eating crusts get
those out of here get those out of here
well it's it's so it's I mean it's so
weird seeing that you can just I guess
sell your own image now but just have an
AI version that they can interact with
so you're not technically selling
yourself but you are kind of at the same
time where how how do you like morally
draw the line or where'd you morally
draw the line with that well that's the
big topic isn't it yeah yeah I guess
with that argument it's kind of up to
the individual really I'm comfortable
doing it then it's like all right well
fine then no one's but maybe no one will
give a [__] yeah there you go yeah
because it's so weird because like I've
like I've been on like YouTube shorts uh
like recently and there have been some
videos it's getting scary to me now
because there have been some videos
where I think the voice is AI generated
like like there's oh no there's so many
of them yeah there's so many so some of
them are like super super obvious like
I'm I'm hearing like a story of like 50
Cent about how he made like his first
million or something yeah and like this
sounds believable enough that maybe this
could be a out of context clip but this
could also be an AI generated monologue
as well and I'm not sure which one it is
and the only way the only way I check is
I go in the comments and I'm like oh
this is AI generated I was like okay
thank God something felt off about this
and I wasn't sure but I was just over
judging is it a terrifying though that
you had to ask other people to confirm
that that's what's so scary to me and
like who knows like all those people in
the comments section might also just be
like getting it wrong yeah yeah exactly
it was a genuine I think this I genuine
so many times has happened now where I'm
like I think this is AI but it wouldn't
surprise me if this was also real
because I have no idea everything that
Joe Rogan has talked about in his
podcast
um and I was just like I and I'm just
like this is actually [__] terrifying
because it's getting to the point now
where I'm having to question whether
some out of context clip is actually AI
generated or is actually a real
monologue that I'm hearing I think I
think uh Philly D said it best where it
was like the AI you hear today is the
worst it's ever going to be yeah well
it's like that's [__] terrifying to
think about that like it's gotten we're
talking about how good it's gotten over
the past like even just year and it's
just gonna [__] because Genoa
terrifies me the most right
um I've had moments where I've heard an
out of context clip from trash taste uh
that has obviously been clipped by a fan
yeah and I've been like I don't remember
[__] saying this
the proof is right there the proof is in
the proof is in the uh video of me
saying it so obviously I said it on like
a previous trash taste like yeah but if
I don't remember what I'm saying now
with real content how the [__] am I
gonna be like like is that an AI sure is
that just a memory issue that is a
memory issue and that is an AI issue
that I'm calling on now because there
might be an AI like generated voice line
of meat that I'm like I don't remember
saying that but [__] am I gaslighting my
am I getting gas there by anyone I might
have been dumb enough I
and put it out of Realm of possibility
for me to actually say this but I think
I said it oh my God don't do that I
guess gaslighting Us in knocking hell
gaslighting us in a [__] 2025 AI
generated trash days content
of God said some real racist [__] here's
the here's the context I was just like I
don't remember no that's not there are
some things I know I wouldn't say but if
there was like a shitty food take I'm
like I don't remember saying that but I
did say maybe I just did say that you
know I couldn't put it past myself to
say that yeah I did say that semen
tastes okay I don't know
but yeah no it's uh it's terrifying but
yeah I mean yeah going back to the idol
thing did uh saw them perform and I was
like I don't get this and then they
ended it off with I think one of the
most
one of the most famous like akb48 songs
I think it was [__] fortune cookie or
something like that oh yeah I don't
[__] know I don't watch this show
yeah yeah and I was like [__] I feel a
bit of Serotonin right now oh no
honestly this is how it starts I'm I'm
you know you say that you missed the
whole idle train you're probably better
off because I was in Japan when the idol
train was kicking off I mean it was
unfucking avoidable like it was God damn
everywhere to the point where my I
tricked myself into liking some songs
that was the only way I could be like I
need this torture to end I'm just gonna
tell myself that this is a banger and
then after a while I was like this is
unironically a banger
is that how they do it could you do that
with any song If you just hear it enough
times you could trick your brain into
thinking you know I used to hate this
but now it's kind of it's kind of fire
now yeah I don't I don't know uh have
you ever been to an Idol concert
yourself uh no uh you wouldn't catch me
dead in one but
but that like you know there's been so
many like again like Japan loves to do
this thing where like if there's a if
there's a song that's popping off at the
moment they're like how many stores can
we put it in oh my God yeah yeah in
Tokyo even just in Tokyo yeah so the
point where it's like you could be
walking just down the street in Shinjuku
and you could hear the same song coming
out of like four different stores at the
same time and it's just like and that
was like that with AKB when they first
came out like some of their like biggest
hits I was just like okay well [__] yeah
we can't go outside anymore I I figured
out the reason why uh hearing like
fortune cookie like fired off some
serotonin in my brain uh because I was
like
I don't know something about this fuel
was homely and I I don't know I don't
know why and so look it up uh and it's
got like [__] 200 million views yeah
the BN the bnk48 has like 200 million
views God damn God [__] damn what the
hell yeah
and I was and uh Sydney told me oh yeah
uh they play that all the time in like
supermarkets in Thailand I was like no
way I would remember this and she was
like no no how have you never every time
we go to like a convenience store on a
7-Eleven in Thailand they play this and
I was like did I just get Gaslight into
liking an idol song like is this is this
on the soundtrack of your life
and I'm like I'm like this this
subliminal messaging have this much
power over me I'm like and I'm like uh I
guess I guess I'm just another sheep
following uh classic sheep yeah classic
sheep it's it's always it's always the
songs that are just like placed in the
most discreet ways all right right where
it's just like you don't even notice
you're just like you listen I've had so
many moments where some person has like
showed me a song where I've heard a song
or like YouTube or something right yeah
and in the back of my head I'm like this
is definitely the first time I'm hearing
this but why do I think I've heard this
before and then I realize it's like oh
it's been I've heard this song maybe
like 50 times just unknowingly yeah yeah
it's just like it's and and then
everything clicks together and you're
just like oh [__] that's how they do it
that's how they get them that's how they
just [__] do that do you think that's
where Deja Vu comes on uh come come yeah
probably like it's just like I've
experienced this before maybe in a dream
or something but it feels oddly familiar
and I don't know if I don't know if it's
uh got any scientific backing I'm sure
figured it out figured it out yeah
didn't know Thailand was like that man
yeah I I'm just fine on it I'm finding
out new things as well yeah I know but
uh yeah also okay
you guys have done the uh Anime Cafe
with Emily right yes
how did it feel
seeing
the anime the demographic of the anime
that uh that you had watched in real
life because uh I went to the bocce The
Rock Cafe
and uh seeing African already seeing
average Bocce The Rock Fans was uh
interesting to say the least break it
down what's the demographic demographic
so I'm like watching The Rock uh Bocce
The Rock right uh what what can I Garner
from this fan base probably probably
they're gonna be I was guessing they're
gonna be probably about my age I was
wrong they were quite a bit older we go
in line everyone is in business suits I
thought I thought I thought that we had
I thought that we were lining up for a
[__] uh katakawa meeting or something
I'm like uh Emily have you gone to the
right place we're not We're not gonna do
a Geeks plus meeting all right are we I
know everyone was lining up for this
Bocce The Rock Cafe in like 50s in like
40s and 50s that all hopefully sounds a
lot like the K on Democrat
I wonder why
is there I don't know
um and they were only like aside from
Emily there were only two other girls
there that uh based
Emily posted a tweet of the picture of
the food put it on screen Mudan it
looked [__] vile yeah it was it was
[__] oh I don't know why of course you
vomit on that omelette like why does it
look like that I saw that and I'm not
the biggest fan of omu rice anyway uh
because I don't like ketchup and uh they
poured ketchup on it over it but somehow
they made it look even more disgusting
by just uh felt like a unicorn vomited
on it uh and they were like that's
that's the dish that's the dish guys oh
it's the pink body it's cold it's it's
Bocce but it's melted it's it's uh Bocce
watching The Rock and uh of course that
one dish uh we we liked to eat there you
had to buy a set meal that costed like
forty dollars that included um and that
was why one of two food items uh that
was like the Savory food item uh I got
like the car there was a chicken curry
which has nothing to do with Bocce The
Rock just easy to make yeah but he had
Rio's face on it so I'm like oh I guess
this is uh Bocce themed ironically
enough like that pink vomit omu rice was
the only real Bocce themed dish on there
um but I was more interested in just
looking around and seeing the kind it
was interesting going to a theme Cafe
and seeing the actual people who watched
the anime the same anime you watched
right yeah because I was asking Emily
what was the cafe that had the most
female like demographic that had the
most female viewers go to that theme
Cafe do you know what I was let me guess
some kind of like either like BL one or
something with like cute boys all right
it was berserk
she told me had the like the had the
highest ratio of girls guys in that Cafe
and I'm like kind of based actually uh
see the waves this is another reason why
she comes to Japan if you want to find a
wife
go to the berserk of it
you'll have something in common what can
I say yeah because you you ain't finding
Andy girls in like the bocce The Rock
Cafe or I'm guessing like most cute
because I was I was surprised that the
demographic was like that old you know
yeah I'm not when I went to the when I
went to them
when I went to the Nichi show Cafe with
Emily that also had quite a few girls
there as well which was also surprising
and I was like okay yeah because I
thought there'd be a lot more boys I
don't know I didn't I never really
thought about like the nichigo
demographic I guess because that's kind
of like open for everyone the one that
was hilarious though was the weathering
with you cafe uh there was no one there
so about to described so that describes
the demographic of that describes that
democracy yeah that describes that
difference
she was literally just Aki and I and
we're just like oh
all right let's just order something get
the [__] out oh God yeah it was sad yeah
I still haven't been to a collab Cafe
that does good food yet I'll let you
guys know I think the ninja Cafe for me
was probably the best one it was a good
food though like the food was decent
what I appreciate about it yeah the one
I appreciate about the nichijo cafe is
that the all the items were actual
references to the show and they did them
in really funny ways I think I think
when it comes to themed cafes the best
food I've had is probably the Kirby Cafe
I just want to go to a place where I get
as good food as something like another
good cafe or restaurant I don't think
you're going otherwise I'm like [__]
this then I'd rather just look at
pictures because what's the [__]
point I think maybe then the Kirby Cafe
might be good because like that's a
permanent store Kirby though I'm kind of
I know you like you look sad
so you're not a fan of happiness I see
dude Kirby's boring as [__] how [__]
days
what the [__] does Kirby do other than
just eat [__] which I can relate to uh
but he's just like come on man do
something he's just a cute little
[__] pink but like any time when I
was a kid and I felt really [__] sad
or angry or you know just had negative
emotions I would just play a Kobe game
depression gone literally kill the game
was a kid and I was like why does this
[__] suck so much oh my God it's not a
game I played one of the DS games which
one it was and it was just I was like
God damn this is like worse than every
other platformer I've played Kirby fans
are just the botchy The Rock Fans of the
audio game industry they're just like oh
look oh look cute pink thing doing
things oh oh
[__] is that how
oh yeah
I take Kirby overboard
[Laughter]
like Kirby is a character I think it's
height but every game but you're not a
Nintendo fan I look yeah I am I love
Nintendo what's your favorite Nintendo
franchise
what counts as being a Nintendo fan
right because I would say I'm a Nintendo
fan even though I don't know if I am an
Nintendo fan I like Nintendo stuff Mario
franchise is probably the best one let's
be real yeah but that's anyone that
breeds at this point yeah but I mean
it's like it's the best like when I
think about Pokemon like there's too
many misses we think about other games
like yeah if someone says like F0 I'm
like [__] off yeah you've had to read
this that's the pretentious yeah there's
two games you haven't played it someone
tells me like a fan I'm like are you
okay uh hey I like us but what's your
favorite all right are you good it's up
there okay all right let's let's Zelda
I'm like understandable no the oldest is
probably the best yeah yeah Zelda's the
best okay what okay let's let's keep
Nintendo for a second let's let's get
keep Nintendo Advance what makes at
which point does someone become a true
Nintendo fan versus just here's some
[__] I played as a kid you know I think
okay this is just my definition of it
from how I see it but like I think it's
one of those things where it's like it's
been with you all your life and you're
still heavily involved in it right right
because it's like you know there's a lot
of games that people like you know a lot
of people especially in our age group
right grew up playing Nintendo games
right it was it was you were either like
team Sony or you were team Nintendo or
team Sega right like that that was the
three genders and like I feel like
Nintendo fans like I classify myself as
a Nintendo fan because I never touched
any of like the Sony stuff I never owned
a Sony console uh yeah I was the most
faithful I was faith I only had Nintendo
consoles growing up so I was like I play
Nintendo games all my life Nintendo
games are still like the main games that
I play yeah to this day as well so like
I would say I'm a Nintendo fan all right
A Game Fan I like get good games and
that's fine yeah like there's a lot of
other games I like but I think at the
end of the day I always go back to
playing Nintendo games like I was always
the Nintendo kid like yeah up to like I
am the Nintendo I
everyone was like are you playing Sonic
and I'm like oh like like I would ever
buy a Sega Mega Drive are you playing
Metal Gear Solid oh what is that a
PlayStation
um is that available on GameCube which
are twin Snakes was about actually
available
but uh yeah up to the GameCube I owned
nothing and I played nothing but
Nintendo games whenever someone talks
about their Nostalgia with Tony Hawks or
some [__] like that I'm like I don't get
that uh I I went to my cousin and he had
a test talk I didn't have it I didn't
like given those away I choose like 10
bucks I did not have I did not have a
PS2 I was like I had this like weird
um like loyalty to Nintendo I was like
no matter what I was like no matter what
all the other kids are playing I refuse
to play anything but the GameCube and
then I became gamer I got an Xbox 360
and then I was like oh good games are on
other platforms as well I mean we had a
PS2 and I remember the one thing about
it was that like we should just get so
many pirated games and it made it so
much cheaper to be able to play on
playstation 2. right because Nintendo
you know they're always full price until
the GameCube kind of like tanked and
then they were yeah okay we've got to do
a few sales uh but yeah the PS2 games
you could just get them super easily
well I'm pretty sure my dad got like
half of them from like the pub yeah he
would just go and some guy would just
give out CDs
he was saying PlayStation drug deals at
the pump yeah I think there was just a
guy who's like yeah if you want to PS2
games
10 over like 50 games yeah and you're
like oh okay yeah I think yeah like look
like no one has the right to like
[__] determine like oh you're a
Nintendo fan you're not a Nintendo fan
it's like [__] whatever right but
like you know I think there's nothing
wrong with like you know like in your
situation where it's like you grew up
playing Nintendo games and then you
discovered other games right and and
you're playing that right yeah but I
think I don't know somewhere deep inside
of me there's still a part of me that's
just like I will always go back to
playing Nintendo game but I I find that
really interesting because I feel like
Nintendo like I I I totally get where
you're coming from because I feel like
Nintendo's the only let's say gaming
brand that has that kind of of brand
loyalty to them because you know back in
the day when there was the console war
you would have people like you know the
Xbox kid
um [__] Sony fans as well but
nowadays it's just like hardcore in
there's hardcore Nintendo fans and then
there are Gamers you know you know what
I mean like just just like there are
idle fans and music fans yeah that's
like no one 's the same no one
was five it's going like Oh I'm a I'm a
[__] PlayStation fan man I I believe
Sony I bullied PlayStation no one does
that I mean during like the Wii U era it
felt like Nintendo was kind of a joke I
mean they were and everyone and everyone
was kind of like [__] Nintendo baby
Nintendo fell off they [__] fell off
and then the switch came and then they
came back with the switch Yeah so it's I
think the loyalty is
will probably only keep up as long as
they keep making good games and consoles
oh of course yeah yeah and they still
make they still make great games but I
have no loyalty to their games like I
used to and I feel like some people will
play Nintendo games below to a company
that doesn't care about you guys yeah
yeah but like like we've talked about
Pokemon before but you know people are
[__] loyal to Pokemon even though
comparatively to the other franchises
like Mario and Zelda I feel like Pokemon
games are a lot worse designed and a lot
worse games I've still played every
single one but that's that's the point
that's the point right I'm like when
Matt when a new Mario comes out what a
new Zelda come out comes out I'm playing
it because it's gonna be a banger game
yeah what a new Pokemon comes out I'm
like this is a 50 50 right now about
whether this will actually be a good
game or not I mean you know in saying
that I haven't enjoyed every single
Pokemon game there's been some real
[__] boring and [__] ones as well a
lot of stinkers yeah but like you know
at the end of the day whenever there's a
new Pokemon game announced I'm I'm gonna
be playing it because I'm just like I'm
like this far in I might as well [__]
see it till the end all right yeah
that's a horrible mentality well you
know like I also am just like genuinely
curious to see like okay you know I've
literally grown up with this franchise
my entire life like some of my most
fondest gaming memories when I was a kid
was playing [__] Pokemon Gold and
Silver on my game boy right like right
like that [__] is like but how far can
Nostalgia go
well that's the thing right and and so
like you know with the with the newest
game for example I was like I saw a lot
of merits in it but I also saw a [__]
ton of flaws in it like everybody else
did and you know as much of a Pokemon
fan as I am I can't ignore the fact that
yeah the newest game was completely
unpolished [__] rushed game yeah
right like I can't deny that but I'm
still gonna play it because I I still
see the little enjoyment that there was
in that game so to see it yeah we had
won the game here we had this discussion
and I remember I was like do not I I
don't want to buy those games I don't
want to be like hey
let me support this practice of you
rushing out [__] all right yeah and
making it seem like it's okay because I
I just don't want to buy games that I
know are going to be like like that that
I know that are rushed because you're
kind of like supporting that almost and
obviously if that's not how you view it
that's not how you view it and it's
totally fine I'm not that's not that's
not me being like you should feel this
way it's like for me just personally I
don't want to be like hey keep making
games this way I'm like no no just take
your time yeah no I totally get that
mentality as well but unfortunately with
Pokemon fans uh that didn't stop no it
absolutely doesn't stop like violet and
skull is still the most sold Pokemon
game ever yeah and I think that that's
more of a testament to the switch being
in more hands than ever yeah yeah like
the amount of switches sold is insane
it's like almost the most sold console
after the PS2 right I'm pretty sure it's
up there I think it's a lot I still
think it's not that much yeah because I
think the DS still if you're out of all
the DS's yeah yeah yeah yeah but it's
still it's still a [__] ton of consoles
especially in this modern day where it
doesn't a lot of the times it doesn't
really matter what console you play
because most games are available on most
consoles now anyway especially if you
have a PC
um PC gaming the most by far still yeah
it's just so easy it's so easy to PC
games I love it I mean I guess if you
haven't if you have a good PC yeah
that's the hurdle isn't it yeah like
just like you know I I also don't give a
[__] about building your own people some
people like you have to build your own
PC yeah it's a pain in the ass but just
buy one yeah you pay a little bit extra
in the parts but that's how everything
when you [__] assemble it costs by a
professional like obviously you have to
pay extra yeah yeah
um you know and it takes a lot of the
stress out of PC gaming because once you
have it it's just a PC we all know how
to use a PC people aren't like
installing games is hard come off it
steam is so goddamn easy yeah I I have
way less stress buying games on Steam
than I do on the Nintendo eShop that
[__] is like nine layers of security I
gotta enter my PayPal did you know how
horrible it is to type on the Nintendo
switch is it good console you're like so
you have to put your information in
every time yeah my PayPal it makes me
put it on every time I just attached my
credit card and it's another fan just as
far like he got
the password
appears to the kingdom in like 10
seconds but like Steve was just so easy
it's so great I love it so much and then
I love that I can tweak the settings
like like because if this motion blur in
the game like off with that right now
right take that off I can change the
frame rate if I want I'm like this is
just great like having this
customization is fantastic yeah
um and like you know even though I've
I've got a steam deck recently which I
like and I just I just wish every
Nintendo game I could play on that
because it's so much better yeah it's so
nice
yeah I'd like for me I would say that I
don't I now I just want a good game
because I barely have time to play games
as it is I wouldn't say I'm a Nintendo
fan because I definitely I definitely
I'm just I'm just a game I would say I I
would say I grew out of Nintendo
actually you're saying that though you
should play Tears of the Kingdom no no
no I will play too far like here's the
thing I don't care if it's made by
Nintendo or not I just care if it's a
good game so the last you know last
games I play from Nintendo have you know
been uh Mario uh
[Music]
Kingdom the breath of the wild completed
that and I know the only reason I
haven't started tears of the kingdom is
because I'm currently trying to touch
grass uh and and uh what's he gonna
start Elder ring though huh when are you
doing Alden ring I would I'll do it
after I finish tea as a kingdom
I'm not trying to get you Jerry I know
you're not gonna play it I know
sometimes she do
some sometimes I don't know sometimes
it's just a Vibe of something I like the
vibe of the whole Zelda aesthetic and
you know breath of the breath yeah
every Masterpiece
this is
just [__] like exactly like breath of
wild yeah I just took like so many
aspects of it no wonder you like it I
don't know I just I the one reason I've
never completed like a soulsborne game
is that I just don't really like the
technology reasons have changed in the
past months huh huh your reasons have
checked it went from I'm definitely
going to play Elden ring I just gotta
wait and now you're like ah doesn't jail
with me anymore I'm like what happened
God no I I I I am going to play because
oh okay okay okay like like he lied as
easily I don't really like the whole
Dark Fantasy setting and yeah yeah I did
dog fantasy is just not for me uh wait
you like berserk that's the thing the
only time I've really got into a dark
fantasy show or story or game is when
it's actually really [__] good so so
the products
no no so the product has to be good
enough to make me to to get over that
hump that it is a dark fantasy setting
right so I know Eldon ring fits in that
category which is why I know I'm gonna
play it it just like it just takes that
extra bit of push to be like oh you
should get into this game because I
don't really like Dark Fantasy stuff I'm
more like a Sci-Fi kind of like person
or what if you streamed it
because then it'll give you the push
that you're making content and you're
finally playing that game you wanted to
play
do I do I want to do that though you
could go the dinosaurs and stream it for
15 hours maybe make content out of it
you know like honkai and genjun I'll
just turn your brain off and kind of do
whatever I would have to like actually
be a gamer if I did Delton ring you know
I don't know if I'm prepared for that
guys I forgot he's a higher verse
streamer there is a difference man they
sponsored you and then they they made
such a good investment they locked you
in for life just a few few lump sum
payments that's how they get you know
they got them unlocked yeah God damn but
in other news uh we're gonna be an ax
But Trash taste is gonna have a big ass
we're leveling
I'm involved yeah Joey uh is having a
family holiday right yeah uh I think we
talked about it before but yeah I'm
going to Vietnam so I unfortunately
won't be at ax this year but these two
will be and uh we're gonna be having a
massive trash taste booth at the
entertainment Hall yeah that should be
interesting because giving a booth today
actually is interesting as well I mean
the whole process was like yeah normally
just for like giant companies yeah I I
mean I saw uh We've so technically it's
already been announced that we're going
to be at ax but I don't think people
know currently that uh we're gonna have
an actual booth there and it's not like
Geeks plus it is like us that's a big
boy yeah it is a big Booth we are
competing against I believe hoyovus
you know they they have booths
some big [__] boys
[Applause]
we're definitely the underdogs in that
room
[Music]
we're just chilling
but uh yeah we kind of decided to do
something for ax because we go every
year and uh this year we tried to uh we
decided to try something a little bit
different and uh try to actually see
what the booth experience is like
because we've seen a lot of other people
try to do booths
um and uh we kind of just wanted a
little bit of experience to what that
was like uh whether we're going to do
more in the future kind of depends on
how well this one plays out because uh
we try to go as big as we could we
didn't like spare any expense without
ideas giant gacha machine yes yes which
has a lot of giant it's huge it's like
12 foot or bigger than that it's massive
yeah yeah
um so big that one of us can get inside
of it so if you go to the Hoya verse
Booth then you can go to albu for like
the real Gadget yeah
all your verse fans genjin fans if if
you if you need that gacha fix just come
to our booth yeah you can watch some of
the figures on the set I think like we
because the gacha because we're the the
main way that we're funding this booth
is by selling limited uh ax merch which
looks [__] sick by the way yeah I
don't know if we can show it but I mean
if we can maybe it looks so [__] sick
yeah especially if you buy some merch
you can spin the giant gacha machine and
yeah some of the prices go up to uh like
this [__] thing get this bad boy yeah
we're getting Goku as well we're getting
the Fate statue
it hurts to uh give the Fate statue away
but you can also win the face statue and
I feel like this is the gonna be the one
that people want the most uh we're gonna
have black Goku or Goku black you decide
it's black owner yeah it's just [__]
yeah
I'm just hyped because you know we
always get asked to be at other people's
booths and I guess it was always kind of
like a it'd be like a fun little I don't
know see see what happens yeah yeah
because like you know like normally only
like giant corporations can do this uh
and we found out why because it's
ungodly expensive it's very expensive so
we were like let's
uh do us a favor do the boys a favor and
uh stop on over check it out uh there's
obviously a bunch of other stuff as well
we're gonna have uh claw machines we've
got a ton of claw machines yeah again
stuff you can only get into photo op
stuff as well yeah we're gonna have a
replica of our set as well yeah where
you can sit uh with the voice you can
finally be a member of trash you can be
the fourth member of trash this is trash
is fortnite overrated yeah yeah let's
find out yeah I think we're just [__]
hired I mean it's been really cool going
through the whole process of yeah
getting a space figuring out how to
build what in it and yeah how much that
costs yeah it's it's it's it's it's it's
been nice it's been eye-opening and I
can see why normally when you need to
have a booth in ax uh you are a big
massive established company uh because I
don't think we're gonna make a profit
from this uh yeah if I'm being honest
I don't know when occasionally yeah we
can't announce when me and Connor are
going to be at that Booth because one of
the big problems is uh we don't want to
cause a fire safety hazard because we
will be kicked out that makes you sound
so badass which is so popular with this
I mean like if people know you're coming
and lines are not good they don't like
lines so yeah we'll be there so just
make sure you tell us sometime we can't
tell you when we'll be there but we'll
be there I'll be there I'll be there in
spirit and Joey will get on a zoom call
with us I'll get on sometime yeah and
yeah we're gonna be filming a bunch of
stuff there as well so come check us out
at uh Anime Expo this year and we have
an actual booth
that's not the only thing we're doing at
ax well not the only thing you're doing
at ax drink what else am I doing at X
did you not want to talk about this oh
oh yeah I did sorry that's not LAX
though yeah that's yeah okay I was like
this has nothing to do with AI yeah I
should have said La yeah we're doing the
the charity auction which I think 100
hopefully should be announced by now and
if it isn't I'm very worried uh yeah on
June 29th we're doing uh well I'm uh
doing a charity event
um where I've just asked a bunch of
YouTubers to bring items to sell for
charity uh really excited for it because
this has been like months months months
months in production and yeah getting it
right and getting it perfect
um you know and the idea has changed a
lot over time initially I was just like
I'll just bring a bunch of my cosplays
and we'll auction them off in front of
like a real crowd uh and then it was
like well you know it kind of seems like
a waste to do all that just for that
because I can do that in my room let's
let's get more people involved and then
as I was getting more people involved I
was like I should just get everyone to
bring an item and we'll auction it off
or yeah so
well yeah like you could be like so some
people because they don't have anything
like physical they can give away they're
just like oh like um you can have an
arrow with me teaching you something or
Oh okay that's cool uh you know because
then that way there's there's different
ways people can get value yeah
um you know and there's some some of
those that I think are I I don't wanna I
don't know what I will and won't
announce before because I kind of want
to get like I want to keep some things a
secret but some things are really cool
and I want people to know it's gonna
happen before
um but I you know and luckily pretty
much everyone I asked said yes so we've
got a ton of really big creators uh and
a ton of really cool items that I'm
super hyped to show off so some really
really expensive stuff and and some
absolutely dog [__] stuff which I think
will make it funny yeah uh and yeah
we're gonna have like a whole real crowd
and people can buy tickets that are very
very expensive
um but then the ticket will I can't
remember what exactly what it was
basically it'll be a donation to charity
right yeah um so very excited for that
is there anything you want to reveal
before or do you want to keep it all a
secret just trying to think what I
should reveal and what I shouldn't keep
seeing because right now I haven't said
anything
um well I mean it's happening in L.A yes
oh yeah it's happening it's happening in
LA but like you know the the tickets are
like there's only like 20 tickets right
so watch online uh it'll it'll be it'll
be fun uh should be able to watch it in
every time zone hopefully
um I'm excited for it we have like an
actual Auction House nice and we have
like a proper Auctioneer guy as well or
no I'm gonna be the Orcs
actually so I'm gonna be the host she's
gonna be auctioneering so I expect you
to do like the whole thing of like oh my
God
I just might not understand what I'm
saying it's cool because they like
people can bid in person and at home
right so it'll be uh interesting to see
how quickly it might go off with people
bidding online yeah right uh versus in
person uh so very excited for it it
should be a fun Little Mix that I don't
think anyone's done before because it's
kind of weird and ambitious yeah and you
know I the whole thing came about
because I was like hey I just want to
Ludwig I was like I'd really like to do
this thing do you reckon you've got you
guys the off-brand would be interested
which is the company that he's a part of
right uh and yeah they were super down
for it and managed to find a good
production company in La so very hyped
for it should be like my most
well-produced stream of all time nice uh
let's hope that people turn up and watch
yeah so I'm sure I'm hot I'm so hyped
for it go check it out we've uh also
donated items yeah gonna be there in
person I'll be there in person I'll be
there in spirit yeah
they're not like a lot of creators that
can't make it uh who are still
interested we'll still be there in some
way so don't worry
um but yeah I think it's uh it's gonna
be a lot of fun I'm super excited for it
yeah it's been a [__] ton of work uh
nice [__] yeah yeah every day I see kind
of messaging like different people being
like oh whatever yeah I've never
messaged many people for a project ever
because I just I always just felt kind
of weird asking people for stuff you
know you've done this before and I was
just like God this is so annoying having
to chase after everyone yeah it's like
hurting cats isn't it yeah well yeah I
mean it's like you know and I understand
because you're asking for someone to
give their time or something of course
you know I under I don't like asking
people for stuff a lot uh and so it was
kind of like I was like all right here
we go Gotta contact literally everyone
I've ever met yeah who is a significant
Creator to kind of get an item and get
them involved in some way
um but I'm really happy so far with the
with the people we we have on board so
really really interesting items as well
oh yeah nice good good and bad items
um excited I can't I couldn't imagine
trying to keep track of that many people
and uh physically then getting the stuff
again yeah turn up is kind of a lot of
work but I mean it should be fun I'm bad
enough okay I'm I guess change the topic
now unless there's something else you
want to say no no that's I mean just I'm
just hyper keep your eye out on keep
your eye out yeah I'll probably talk
more about it when maybe I don't know
when we're coming up to it or when I
don't know when it when it's done I have
no idea yeah just turn up come watch
trainline to June excited yeah um I'm
bad enough keeping up with uh messaging
people who like owe me money you know
I [__] despise it man the I I feel
like I'm the type of guy who if it's
just like a small amount of money I'm
just like [__] it whatever let's just
forget about it I don't think I don't
think anyone likes being the Repo Man
you know because being like Oh by the
way I'm here to take your
if I can pay a debt I I hate being in
debt right because I know I know the
pain of the person who is waiting not
not even like even if they're not
waiting for money you know the fact that
they have to go out their way to like
message me to be like you need to pay
your money because I know I know I'm
gonna forget I know I'm gonna [__]
forget man yeah sure yeah oh I'm also
doing a panel with Iron Mask I forgot
about that of some time at ax so that'll
be fun oh yeah we don't be streamed as
well we don't have our full ax schedule
right now I'm I'm sure I'm gonna have
some events uh I'll just try to check
out on Twitter yeah just just check out
just check out our Twitter that's pretty
well actually we'll actually update it
for once you know excited I I like going
uh to anime expert it's always crazy I
mean you just see the most insane
cosplayers yeah it's just very busy I
can't wait to see the amount of honkai
cosplayers this year I'm calling it now
have just taken over cosplays right last
year like last year I was surprised not
really surprised actually kind of
surprised because I knew genshin was big
I was not surprised I don't know okay I
knew Genji was big I didn't know I
didn't like a year is like quite a long
time in my mind right uh because that
was was it last year last year was the
first time that we had gone to
conventions yeah again after like covert
and everything and I knew gention was
big and it was then that I realized how
big gentian was you know
um and with how big honka I think uh how
big honkai I think is going to be
um that's just gonna like they've just
monopolized pretty much every cosplayer
I mean it's because all their characters
are just so cosplayable it's like it's
like these character designs are built
for cosplay yeah you know the amount of
cosplayers and artists that don't even
play the games well like yeah I just I
just do it because I like it just looks
like yeah yeah do you remember like
previous cosplays uh or previous
conventions where there would always be
like that one character at uh every yeah
every convention every year there was
always like a heart there's always
Kirito and Asana yeah yeah that was way
longer yeah for me okay yeah for me the
one the one character I never understood
because I didn't realize it was this
popular was uh jinko enoshima from
Duncan Romper there was so many and I
did not understand why because I didn't
my friendship group like we had one
person that played Danganronpa and it
hardly talked about it so I was
surprised that
this one particular character was just
this popular and pretty much every anime
convention I went to that year yeah what
and it's only junco yeah
yeah Duncan Romford characters just
jinko and Ashima yeah why is that I
don't know another one I always see so
much of even to this day is uh [__]
uh yumiko from um kakiguri oh yeah you
see that still to this day so many
kakaguru cosplays when the cosplay is
easy you know like yeah you know that's
an anime that is kind of easy to call
it's pretty easy yeah you get a little a
normal school-esque outfit throwing a
wig yeah yeah I think it's it's like a
but junko is not easy yeah was not easy
but I I mean I guess it's easy to wear
as well I guess kind of more the closer
it is to normal attire the easier it is
I'm starting to see a pattern here okay
so jinko uh umeko yeah uh yuno gaso from
same characters [__] but also it's also
kind of easy to cosplay Kimiko toga from
my hero Academia as well [__] oh my God
what is it with what is it
is pretty good though because you got to
do a lot of work you gotta get the thing
yeah yeah yeah yeah like all the all the
cosplays I've seen of all these
characters are [__] sick like they
look so good like I could never do that
[__] obviously but like yeah it's it's
all the insanity
all the insane characters because
they're like they're just like me for
real oh my God yeah I can fix it
yeah
I don't know yeah yeah
it'll be all chainsaw man this year oh
yeah [__] I wonder how many machim
powers easy so yeah we'll see a lot of
it sure there are quite a few hockey
cosplayers already like from the few
conventions yeah I thought chainsaw mine
was already pretty popular when I well
did you see the um the mapper thing from
the I don't know let's see I don't know
which guy it was he was just like yeah
chainsaw man didn't do as well as we
kind of thought it would do the Jujitsu
question did way better yeah it was
actually a uh commercial floor yeah yeah
like really yeah like they they I saw in
an article like they made close to no
money off of Chainsaw man yeah
I think they don't even think I think
the article headline that at least I saw
yeah this is me reading article
headlines in the article it's like
chainsaw man was a success but didn't
have the same impact that Jitsu Tyson
did yeah for the company yeah like for
mapper I don't get it
yeah you know the chainsaw man kind of
uh came and everyone was like yo and at
least in Japan this is not online this
is Japan I was like yo chainsaw man
three months and it was like okay
and then and but like where's Jiu Jitsu
Tyson it felt like it just wouldn't
leave yeah yeah just felt like it was
and then the movie came out and that was
huge and the movie was a huge commercial
it just felt like Jujutsu kaisen hype
did not die in Japan and then I guess
when I heard that I was like yeah that
does kind of make sense when I when I
think about how it was being in Japan
only not nothing to do with yeah online
discourse or anything like that just
being in Japan judiciency was [__]
everywhere I think what Jesus Christen
did really well was that they kind of
had this like constant stream of new
content happening as well because it was
like the first season happened and then
not too long after that there was like
the movie and in between that there was
lots of promotional stuff and now like
you know second season and all that kind
of stuff whereas chainsaw man it was
kind of just like his 12 episodes
and nothing so far yeah right here's the
weird thing though when did people start
getting hyped over judiciason because it
right away really because it felt like
did you start watching it right away
because it felt like when I first
started watching like let's say the
first Arc of digital geisen I was like
oh this is a high top news Shonen that
uh everyone talked about let's see what
it's about I'm like oh it's it's good
it's good
um and like not many I didn't really see
much discussion or talk about it and
then it just felt like overnight
everyone was watching it and I was like
when did when what happened or when did
this happen at which stage did everyone
start watching Jiu Jitsu Kyson because
you know at least because of the moment
when Gojo came out oh [__]
no no you know what it was it was the
[__]
that's it that high scene was clipped
and uploaded everything
all right I also think like I when I
watch chainsaw man I I thought it
honestly even as well when you compare
them both you're like
Chancellor man is maybe a little too
much like in terms of like like you know
when you think about a general audience
yeah yeah like it's it's very sexual
very very sexual very weird it's very
weird the gore is [__] intense which
makes fit for all things that I love and
I really [__] dig it but I could see
how on like a general scale how
something like adjudication would be way
easier to Market yeah yeah you know when
you have these characters and yeah it's
about killing [__] you know there's
not guns and there's not humans being
killed a lot of times it's mainly these
spirits and yeah some of the cast you
know maybe some of them get hurt and
stuff but you know what I mean like it's
it when you sit down and look at it from
like a business perspective it would
make way it doesn't Mark all sense in
Japan as a whole that something like
judiciason would pop off more even
though chance man was marketed towards
like teenagers here I mean I feel like
that's that's I feel that's like a
reason why I like for example was so
huge yeah yeah because I think on a
broader scale of things it's so much
more aspects to that show that are just
so much easily marketable to as wide of
an audience as possible whereas chainsaw
man I feel a lot of the hype that was
created around chainsaw man was it was
two-part it was the fans of the manga of
Chainsaw man yeah and the fact that map
is named it definitely felt yeah
definitely felt like the Western hyper
it was was so much more intense than
what I saw in Japan yeah yeah for sure I
also feel like
it's you know I also feel like chainsaw
man only being 12 episode kind of hurt
it a lot as well yeah like I I feel like
that was the biggest Factor because I'm
kind of kind of realizing now especially
with long-running battle Shonen you need
more than 12 episodes to sell a Shonen
show I mean Demon Slayer now one of the
highest grossing anime franchises of all
time uh before episode 18 I remember no
one really [__] watched Demon Slayer
and then suddenly everyone was watching
Demon Slayer because of like one bang a
moment uh in episode 18 and I remember
for that moment I was like and I I
remember I literally made a video about
Demon Slayer being like Oh I don't I
don't think many people are watching
this when it first came out and then
um it just blew up overnight and I feel
like something similar happened with Jiu
Jitsu kaisen as well where it kind of
goes your license
sorry certification I only had 12
episodes though right no I had 12. 24.
I mean like Finland Saga now I'm
watching it weekly and I'm like I
already know what's gonna happen but I
love I [__] love that we have 20 like
I can get my teeth in it you know what I
mean 20 24 episodes I'm like all right
buckle up all right it feels like my
watching it weekly the investment is
worth more yeah yeah I wonder if it's
gonna it's gonna swing around yeah
because I feel like we've chainsaw man
it's like the 12 episodes barely got me
invested into well they didn't they
didn't even get like the meat of the
store yeah right yeah yeah it does kind
of suck because you know and they're
like all right wait three years now yeah
what yeah exactly because it's like if I
compare the first 12 episodes of Jesus
Tyson we're gonna start War right now by
the way uh if I compare the first 12
episodes of Jesus Christ versus the
first web episode is chainsaw man I
would say I'm more for chainsaw man but
now that the final product is there
there were more Banger moments in
Jujitsu geisen because it had uh had 24
episodes and uh had some really really
good [__] fights in the second half
which is my favorite part of the first
season foreign
has even come close to reaching his Peak
which is why it's it's good they're both
good but they're both shows they're both
Shonen shows that in my eyes have not
come close to reaching their full
potential yet it's just a question
season two 24 episodes as well yes
I mean they'd be doing a disservice if
they only gave you 12 episodes I'd
rather wait yeah I'd rather wait like
three years and get 24 episodes than
wait one year and get 12 episodes
because yeah I I don't know what it is
something about like yeah you you often
can't reach a good climax in 12 episodes
without it feeling rushed for like this
kind of Shonen yeah I mean I feel that's
why like the latest seasons of like
Attack on Titan struggled a lot right
because it's like we were only given
like yeah we get small increments of
like 12 episodes where it would have
just been much better if we just gave us
a huge chunk of 24 episodes to actually
invest ourselves in and now like the
hype for it is like kind of slowly doing
handling away because it's like oh [__]
we have to wait again yeah the
continuation yeah yeah I'm I'm kind of
starting to realize how unimpactful or
12 episodes is because there's a lot
there's so many 12 episodes anime that I
like but now when I think about the
anime I'm excited about it's every it's
all of them that have like multiple
Seasons yeah yeah that have a longer
ongoing story than just 12 episodes I'm
trying to I'm trying to think of like
imagine if one percent of the power that
one piece animation had was put into
other [__] we did get so many episodes
we just so many episodes dude I don't
know I I I yeah I I definitely again
like watching Finland Saga really has
made me appreciate that yeah like I mean
map is animating that yeah the fact they
were given so much time to let that
story breathe and you know because I
think there could have been an argument
where a lot of fans would be like the
[__] far Mark is boring yada yada
it's not that's what I'm saying like
this is what like maybe people would say
because a lot of people are worried that
anime Watchers wouldn't like the the new
season of Inland song is like what the
[__] why is nothing happening yeah yeah
um but I I think it really really helps
sell their story in particular and helps
get the message across by just having
this kind of slow progress and and
letting you go through it in a way that
isn't rushed because because I do think
there could have been a world where it
could have been rushed and it could have
been glossed over 12 episodes yeah for
sure it wouldn't have been good but I
think it could have been done well I
think the problem is right now that
there is so much anime being made and
most of them have to do in two episodes
right and most of them are 12 episodes
right so
um even if you have a banger 12 episodes
just by having 24 episodes it will stick
out more in people's minds because
they've consumed more of it compared to
like other shows and I'm looking at a
lot of these like 12 episode shows that
I've watched uh and a lot of them I know
like I think the last one that had like
a massive impact was probably like Bocce
the rock you know but that's because it
was like something new you know
I can't really think of a lot of 12
episode shows that stick in people's
mind years after they air you know uh
whereas I think now now like The Meta is
having
I think you know having longer running
series will run over multiple Seasons
yeah yeah and also releasing them in a
way that it makes sense like I mean
again we spoke about this on a prior
podcast but you know JoJo hype was
killed by how it was released on Netflix
yeah yeah and I think if it was if that
was just they were like hold up let's
just wait an extra year and a half or
two years and let's just drop it all in
one go it would have done better or I
think even better yet I I kind of prefer
just the weekly model as the older I've
gotten and I don't know why the more I
don't I can't the more I kind of like
the weekly Model A lot I'm like yeah I
like this I can get invested over a
course of a long period of time
I [__] myself over with oceanico and
hell's paradise and I hate it I hate
waiting a week for an exit episode you
hate that I like that I just want to
watch the next episode and I think one
of the things I like most about that is
that the show can come out and and I can
reflect on my life as the show is coming
out because
mean because like sometimes it's like a
a 50 episode series right yeah and it's
I I can be like damn I've been watching
this for a whole year and I can think
about how that I've had this whole thing
to look forward to and I can think back
to like what where you know where I was
but I I I really like that I don't know
why like being a part of something for
that long is kind of nice yeah
um you know whereas when you binge it I
don't feel the same one piece
I genuinely think like one piece fans
they must get like this because you know
I mean obviously I'm still reading it
but I'm not reading it like weekly but
yeah it must be kind of cool to follow
something like one piece fans who have
been following it for like 10 plus years
it must be pretty [__] cool to follow
one piece and have it kind of Follow
Your like life that's kind of yeah
that's kind of sick I mean as is that
one piece fan and you know also as
someone who's had some franchises that's
happened to me before I think the
biggest one that sticks out my mind is
Ava Ava wasn't exactly a weekly show it
wasn't exactly a weekly wait to get the
next piece of Ava but I waited we were
able fans we waited and you know seeing
it come to an end after a [__] 25 and
then you couldn't imagine how you were
when you first watched the second one
yeah yeah yeah and you look back but you
know cool I I don't I don't I feel like
a year is not enough time for me to be
like emotionally invested enough to be
like oh I've I've watched that so much
changes in a year I think it's important
to self-reflect on your past year
because like for me uh my biggest thing
I look for whenever I watch anything
doesn't even matter if it's animes just
to get like immersed in the story right
of course that's why I kind of I'm fine
with watching us TV shows a lot of time
weekly because they're like an hour long
20 minutes is barely enough it's not
enough yeah yeah it's barely enough time
for me to like properly get immersed in
a story which is which is why I love it
then because I feel super good that when
I maybe one week I was super busy and I
couldn't watch the show and then you
have two episodes to watch you like oh
yeah
oh yeah grab some popcorn get a drink 40
minutes yeah
I don't know I think someone else must
be relating to this it's certainly it's
just a treat when you know I I get I get
the sentiment yeah it's so nice I've
just never thought of myself
yeah and I'm sure we'll be like that for
me because I'm gonna try my goddamn
hardest to not watch for the first few
weeks so that I can because you know a
lot of anime suffer from the first few
episodes
it's like my personal rule with Demon
Slayer uh from like the past like from
the second Arc onwards I was like I'm
not watching a goddamn episode till
episode 8 is out yeah because it's it's
usually a blue bold till episode eight
yeah like nothing happens most of the
time uh except the sawdark a lot I did
that rule and then like two episodes in
stuff started happening I was like oh
okay that's good that's nice way to the
whole season's over so I can just be
injured yeah I need at least like five
five abs so it's I watched like five
episodes that's how I get properly
hooked yeah but I have that five or six
episode binge yeah and then I can be
like now I'm gonna do the white weekly
because I know it's worth it now with
Shonen it's it's okay there are some
series I can maybe like bend the rules
and watch weekly Shonen is my own
impossible because the amount of times
I've tried this before where I've
watched it it's the first episode of the
fights you are just getting invested and
you're like damn shit's about to shit's
about to pop off episode ends so you
wait a week you're like I've forgotten
what's happened oh yeah they're in a
fight okay let's let's it's about to pop
off and then there's always like the
there's always like the three-stage act
in the fight where at first it looks
like you know things are going well or
maybe the maybe this time the
protagonist is losing and you're in my
mind I'm just like okay I'm waiting for
the episode where the protagonist turns
it around yeah and it's not that episode
it's the next episode so I gotta invest
myself again wait a week and then in a
single fight last three [__] week I'm
like
I didn't even I I heard third part is uh
protagonist makes a realization about
themselves yeah and uses that knowledge
to fight yeah and I'm like [__] this is
is enough this is enough time for me to
use my brain you know I'm like I know
what's going to happen uh and you know
it's it's not enough time to like
reinvest back into that fight to really
see the hype moment where the
protagonist turns it around or that hype
moment happens in the fight you know
especially with Shonen there needs to be
like a natural progression in the fight
for both you the
rocky the rock is like yeah I could
watch that Weekly uh I'm just like yeah
turn my brain off because nothing
[__] happens
oh she's just like me for real okay
that's enough yeah it's yeah they're
definitely not Shonen but uh that's why
I kind of I I like the Netflix model
even though I would still like them to
release weekly just because
I would you know I have patience I can
wait until this I I pay I can win yeah I
I I I can wait we we we get bigger hype
for series and I don't the problem is
that I don't know what hype translates
to for like profits like there's hype
help at all like probably right because
you can probably sell more merch I mean
it didn't help man yeah well I wonder I
wonder how chainsaw Man released in
Japan I don't know if it was on TV what
time slot it was on because Japan
sometimes [__] [__] anime over and
they stick yeah I think chainsawanda was
on like most streaming sites from what I
remember in Japan as well
um so I think they did a decent job then
like compared to like some of the older
shows but I can easily see a world where
chainsaw man struggle to find a solid
demographic that really it's [__]
weird because it kind of touches a lot
of I guess kind of different niches that
would appeal to different kinds of
people but none of them are all like
like brought you the rock like you said
you know the 50 year olds are going to
show up you know what I mean like like
chainsaw man who do you who you 100
targeting here because it's like edgy
teenagers just sure just young young
people young adults probably 40 year old
man probably it's a little too weird for
them like you know what I mean like it's
it's such an odd it's an odd show that
appeals to I think just hardcore anime
and manga fans yeah which is great
because it's it's a it's in a [__]
amazing show and I don't think anyone
would argue it's not but I think I I can
100 believe that it probably had a hard
time just selling itself to no
demographic in a way that would
meaningfully make money but is there are
some franchises like okay the biggest
the biggest one that has never made
sense to me right
it's a Evangelion yeah I'm just like
why why this because if you look at the
history of like anime franchising uh in
Japan Ava was one of like the first that
had such like a massive hit all around I
mean we had like obviously like Mecca
before like Gundam and everything like
that but Ava was just everything
everything about this was seen
everywhere it was a cultural phenomenon
and I'm like the time it came out and
the type of show it was I think if it
ever came out today it probably wouldn't
be yeah but he like you look at Ava and
I'm like this doesn't look like a
marketable show you look you look at
what's happening on screen and you you
just no one's looking at being like
more marketable than chainsaw man you
think so I think so because okay first
of all Max Max are great for money uh
number one because because you could you
can sell the max they're iconic uh
number two uh I think the main character
I think Shinji is way easier for sale
than dingy I think oh no oh no because
I'm a disagree are you there because as
we've learned from Bocce The Rock
socially anxious characters that are
depressed who [__] resonate they do
well Dentures is too happy go lucky no
no no no man he's too horny because you
don't wanna you don't want to
identificate okay look look you don't
want to be that horny look you you need
to go with you know the the reason Genji
works then she's the best mate denji's
not the guy you want to be then she's
the guy you want to have as your mate oh
denji denji I feel resonates more with
today's audience than uh denji is the
guy that everyone wishes they could be
but they're too scared to admit yeah
because that's okay you look at you look
at someone like uh mid area right good
good kid follows the rules oh oh I just
want to be a good boy nobody [__]
thinks like that anymore you know yeah
like you you look at [__] we're
[__] grown ass adults guys you
[__] look at the you [__] look at
like teenagers now and they're like yeah
I'm a [__] dingy what do I give a
[__] about I don't know I actually don't
know I just want to touch themselves I
just want to touch some attention denji
definitely would subscribe to an only
fans if he had [__] income okay look
denji
I'm trying to make an argument for some
[__] I made up for a show I don't like
listen I think that Shinji being a
little [__] boy probably helped a lot
that was they had sex and Eva I think
right there's calm on the hands or
something someone had sex but it wasn't
Shinji
I know this is through memes only it's
like yes I had to have that 30 second
sex scene where I show everything the
xinji like fell on top of a naked Ray
and still got no [__] like he's got no
hope bro yeah yeah but like I came out
wait wait when did they get 90s 1995 95.
what a horny year that was I can see I
can see why it worked I thought I think
maybe Ava might have like kind of banked
off of the whole like 90s OVA era of
just like I think anime fans in general
were just looking for more weirder out
there unique [__] yeah I don't think Ava
would be like Ava would not work today
yeah no way yeah I think it just came
out at the perfect time and it was that
one show that was like it's just also
Banger opening yeah of course yeah
it is
but like I think
I think it was one of those shows where
like it it came off a time where people
were looking for something that was like
weird and unique but still not so weird
that it alienated its entire fan base
and I feel like evil was just like kind
of a right on the cusp of that
uh from the Japan perspective you know
the struggle of being a teenager who's
being told what to do and yeah you're
kind of struggling with that that's a
very I mean obviously that's a very
Universal concept but I think very much
so in Japan where it's like I'm a
teenager and I'm I'm struggling with my
identity here I don't know where all my
places in the world and all the adults
are telling me to do all this stuff so I
think that's also a massive reason why
I'm successful yeah and again it was
horny
um I think I think as well Ava just like
really grew from just like Word of Mouth
luckily I think I don't know this is all
speculation I've made based off only
watching One season and [__] yeah
because like I feel like Not only was
Ava like so like I think the people who
really liked it it started off kind of
smallish and then it kind of Grew From
just a word of mouth because anime was
just getting more I guess
normal to watch in the late 90s and
early 2000s and then not to mention like
the countless number of like people in
the industry who like directly you know
looked at Avon was like that was a huge
influence or like you know that we took
a lot out of Eva and it's like I think
it's just like the combination of the
influential factor in the industry and
just the fact that it just came out at
the perfect time and it's just like
everything just came together with a
banger opening on top of that a cherry
on top there you go yeah because I I
think the big difference uh between
something like say chainsaw man and Ava
is that I think they just have different
demographics like period I think Ava has
I think the topics explored in Ava
probably
resonated with a lot of the older
working like uh generation in Japan at
the time where there was a lot of this
societal pressure
um once you grew out once you you know
graduated from high school and
everything
um and that kind of like story
um really resonated with the whole
generation of people in Japan and I
think that's one of the big reasons why
it became the massive hit that it did uh
and then 30 years later they became
Bocce fans
actually
you know
they were once in their 20s Ava fans I I
would argue that I think Ava fans and
Bocce fans have more in common than
Bochy fans and uh chainsaw man fans oh
sorry then uh like are more likely to
have something in common than Bochy fans
and jeans yeah I mean yeah I I truly
believe that James a managed hasn't
found it's it's it's a die-hard audience
yet that it appeals to I mean I I think
I think they exist but it's only in the
manga form right now yeah maybe I mean I
I don't know I also think it's harder to
sell merge for chainsaw man because yeah
yeah it's just even you don't do
anything yeah hey I mean a chainsaw man
is just a little bit edgier it's a
little bit it's a little bit too weird
for the regular yeah yeah and juicy
Kyson I feel is that perfect Middle
Ground from you know there's uh let's
say my hero Academia the kind of like
the poster child of
like safe kind of like he is like it's
got a very similar vibe to like gants
almost like very horny yeah very gory
all right chainsaw man yeah oh yeah
um
[__] [__] no [__] with foxes
but like I think Gans came out at a time
when edginess was was very much in
demand I think edgy edginess is cool not
as in as it used to be I think people
are kind of over oh again because like
all these shows banked off of the
[__] edgiest period of anime which is
the 90s OVA period like those were some
of the edgiest [__] shows ever I feel
like there will always be a space for
edginess
but it's not as in the Forefront as it
used to yeah I think it goes in and out
of being in the mainstream popularity
but there'll always be a demand for edgy
shows because like in terms of like Peak
popularity because like I'm waiting for
like I'm not sure already exists but
whatever this generation's Mirai Nikki
will be uh because every every okay here
hear me out hear me out every generation
every generation has a [__] show that
for some reason when you're a [__]
teenage kid my hero slapped so hard all
right for me it was like for me like the
the progression goes elf and leads yeah
uh Mirai Nikki yeah uh akame got kill oh
God right yeah and I'm like what is what
is this generation is going to be I've
prayed to God it's not chase
the man is
good or are we just saying that like we
used to say with Mirai Nikki
again
notification I thought Alvin Lee was a
banger shot
oh my God they had so much Gore like
like do you remember the phase where uh
you're like guys adults uh guys anime
actually foreign
[Music]
in that same category because it is
actually it's actually a good shot is
[__] amazing because yeah like I said
I think we just think it's like a little
too cold yeah yeah a little too edgy to
right now for it to crush mainstream
yeah yeah I hope it does though I hope
it does I [__] hope so too I haven't
read further on the manga apparently it
just oh my God second half is Juicy I
don't know if this is a controversial
take don't [__] animate a new intro
outro every time just give me [__]
more episodes yeah I'm gonna be real
yeah
I kind of feel like they did that that
was Overkill yeah that it was it was
Overkill it was awesome yeah but it was
too much yeah okay because here's the
thing right Attack on Titan obviously
gory obviously edgy right
um but do you feel like that was
successful because it just never kind of
like tried to be a Shonen or try to
Market itself as a young audience and it
went here is a mature kind of like story
right from the get-go yeah maybe perhaps
yeah it's hard to say because Attack on
Titans success is a really weird one
it's a bit of an anomaly yeah yeah but I
think no one would say isn't deserved
yeah
um but I mean yeah in Japan it's still
huge is [__] massive yeah and it's
kind of in its own bubble in that right
where like no other show is kind of like
it or done as well as it in Japan it's
just very weird it's very awesome I feel
like that's just because that's I mean
marketability aside if you have a good
story like Attack on Titan then at the
end of the day you're gonna get fans and
people are gonna try and find a way to
sell it it's also like the Titans are
pretty [__] iconic yeah and even if
you don't know Attack on Titan you've
seen a Titan you know yeah and you
you're like well not in real life
obviously well you might have seen one
like you know what I mean they're so
easy to spread and I I don't know I feel
like it's
yeah it's so bizarre it's it's so it's
such an interesting it has it has such
like noticeable like imagery and like
recognizable imagery that's no other
show looked like or will probably ever
look like right yeah so that definitely
helped whereas like you know as vividly
as Vivid like visually chainsaw man was
like you know it's not exactly the most
like outlandish like unique visuals when
it comes to like character designs or
anything like that right so I think
maybe that might be another aspect where
it's like it's not as instantly
recognizable I feel like maybe chainsaw
man just hasn't had enough time yeah I
feel like I feel like it needs to cook
just a little bit longer let them cook
yeah I'm I'm [__] hoping that the
next season when it comes out whenever
the [__] comes out that it really does
I'm just saying as someone who's right
ahead the second half of Chainsaw man is
[__] wild like yeah I just want them
to be financially [__] God I want
them to print money yeah just yeah we
get more yeah sure sure all right well
that's all you know monthly anime tour
no more now no more no more foreign
are you a chainsaw man fan I bet you are
yeah do you think chainsaw man should be
more popular more marketable let us know
in the comments but I think do you think
judiciency is better than chainsaw man
let's just start a war right I will I
will block you if you do say that but uh
hey if you'd like to support the show
then go to our patreon patreon.com trash
days also follow us on Twitter send us
your memes on the subreddit and if you
hate a face listen to us on Spotify and
uh for those of you guys going to ax uh
I mean I won't see you there but they'll
see you they'll see you there about our
booth all right so you're at the charity
auction as well we should have watched
that yep all right see you next week bye
[Music]
thank you